day after day the Ukrainian Port of
mariupo has withstood Russia's
Relentless Onslaught and refused to
surrender but the city is all but
destroyed many have left supplies of
basic goods are running out fast is this
how Russia plans to strangle other
cities across Ukraine
my guest this week is markian lubkiewski
advisor to the country's Minister of
Defense how long can this all go on till
the last Ukrainian will be killed
and this is not only nice words so the
moral and the spirit of ukrainians are
very is very high as the fighting
intensifies we look at the narrow path
to a peace Accord and the prospect that
Ukraine faces years of stalemate what
motivates people enduring such dire
conditions and while they give their
life and their future for their country
do they feel that their allies who
promised so much have given enough
all that and much more on conflict Zone
[Music]
foreign
welcome to conflict Zone
thank you for having me with you
as Russia steps up its attacks fighting
words from your president Ukraine he
said we'll never bow to Russian
ultimatums and he made clear there'd be
no compromises on territorial Integrity
or sovereignty but he wants to talk to
Mr Putin is there anything to suggest
that Russia wants to talk constructively
to him
thank you Tim
uh look this initiative was raised a
couple of times by President zielinski
and uh yeah he is ready to speak to
President Putin to discuss all issues
including military
humanitarian political
but we are we we still did not get any
any reply from the Russian side that
Russian side is ready to discuss that
let me remind you one one very
interesting thing for me as a diplomat
you remember recently uh where
negotiations between Minister of Foreign
Affairs of Ukraine Metro culeba and his
counterpart minister lavrov and uh after
that negotiations there was a statement
made by lavrov he said that Russia will
never attack any European or other
European country
and after that he added and Russia never
attacked Ukraine
uh so so even if you got a deal you
wouldn't trust it
is that what you're saying we need to
have very strong guarantees provided not
only by Russia but also by such
countries as the United States United
Kingdom
G7 European countries EU and probably
our neighbors
you had those guarantees or some of
those guarantees with the Budapest
memorandum going back to 1994
guaranteeing your security in return for
you giving up your nuclear weapons that
didn't work so well then did it what
makes you think it will work better now
we need to establish new system of
security you're absolutely right saying
that you're the best memorandum never
worked and now we need to include all
parties and to to find such guarantees
which should be really workable for
everybody not only for Ukraine because
in in this circumstances nobody can be
safe
uh look today Putin attacked Ukraine why
tomorrow he wouldn't attack Poland or
Lithuania Estonia Latvia
nobody can be sure right now
a week ago your president's top
negotiator Michael podoliak went so far
as to say the Russian position had
softened significantly we have much
confidence he said that we'll have a
ceasefire in the coming days what
happened to that confidence
I think that there are two reasons so I
cannot disclose the matter of
negotiations I'm not the part of
negotiating team but there are two main
reasons why uh position or approach of
Russian Federation became much more
softer first of all the losses of Russia
in Ukraine are are tremendous they the
the Russians lost already 15 000 their
soldiers here and the second thing that
sanctions are working so it these two
reasons are the the base of or or the
matter why Russians are ready to speak
to speak in a much more softer way but
there's some suggestion in the west that
Russia sees negotiations not as a way to
end conflict but as part of that
conflict as one Diplomat said just a way
of dialing up and dialing down the tempo
to suit Russia's needs what do you think
we don't we don't want to to face with
the Frozen conflict you are absolutely
right I agree with you so and this is
the strategy of the tactics of Russia
Russia made a couple of Frozen conflicts
on the territory of Soviet Union
Azerbaijan Georgia uh Moldova so and
probably if they will not succeed in the
coming days and they will not they will
try they will try to Frozen the conflict
you say you don't want a frozen conflict
but how long can you go on like this
with critical shortages of food water
and Medicine in the main areas under
attack tens of thousands of people
homeless people sleeping in basements
people dying on the streets how long can
this last
till the last Ukrainian will be killed
and this is not only nice words so the
moral and the spirit of ukrainians are
very is very high and the spirit and the
experience and effectiveness of
Ukrainian Army as well so we will fight
till the end
the situation is really very dramatic if
we are speaking about such cities as
mariupo as chernihir and then hark you
so uh I I got an impression that Putin
is going to to demolish a Ukraine
totally and to kill all ukrainians so
it's looking like looks like this is his
strategy and this is his main goal but
we will fight till the end
in the U.S President Biden has been
warning that Russia could use chemical
and biological weapons how seriously do
you take that threat
very seriously
first there were accusations regarding
Ukraine that Ukraine will use these
chemical weapons that we are working on
birds taking the biological weapons to
to Russia or munition this is crazy so
we should be ready everybody should be
ready and don't forget that Russia is a
one of nuclear Powers so they can use
also nuclear weapons and this is this is
terrible so you remember that a couple
of days ago zaporiza Nuclear Station was
attacked with the Russian missiles so
that's why we are we are ready for any
kind of scenarios in the last 72 hours
your forces admitted they'd lost access
to the Sea of azov that strip of
Coastline that connects Crimea to the
Breakaway regions of Donetsk and lucansk
how serious is that loss for you
situation in mariopol is very seriously
so that's why we are trying to take care
and to rescue other people so the spirit
of people defending I mean uh soldiers
Ukrainian soldiers defending mariupo is
is very high so again they will they
will fight till the end so the main
thing for us is to create to establish
uh so-called humanitarian corridors and
take people out from the areas which are
on the attacks unfortunately Russians
are shooting on other people they are
trying to kill everybody who is who is
leaving mariupo chernihiv or some other
cities this is terrible
reports from Mario Paul have spoken
about how it's almost completely
destroyed
is is it close to the end is it close to
the point where it simply cannot take
any more
uh 90 of the infrastructure of mariupo
is is demolished
so this is our new Aleppo so uh I I
don't want to to do any any forecasting
it's it's very hard for me but we will
fight uh you know uh it's it's
tremendously hard to accept that but we
are trying to do our best and our our
soldiers are a real heroes there
if
proper talks began constructive talks
with the Russians began how far is your
government United on what it will or
won't negotiate to get a deal
it's it's it's very important our
government is United you know that and
together with the Parliament and the
president is staying in Kiev as you know
he he will not escape and I think it's
important to speak to Ukrainian people
and the president will will do that so
in case he will he will face with the
with the issues he cannot saw himself so
I think that our society is is United
maybe for the first time in in our new
history so it's important to keep it
United and the main things
so far it is ceasefire and to establish
mentioned mentioned humanitarian
corridors
your president's spelled out as we said
his red lines about territorial
integrity and sovereignty so you would
never accept the annexation of Crimea is
that also a red line
yes sure annexation of uh Crimea was
illegal was made in in the military way
so that cannot be accepted same two uh
two territories or the temporary
occupied territories of donask and
hugansk regions so but it's important to
sit and to speak we are ready for such
kind of negotiations for your
informations for your information
negotiations are ongoing other diplomas
are speaking to to Russians right now
if those red lines are standing what's
left some kind of negotiated neutrality
for Ukraine
you know that the other aspiration is to
become the part of a civilized world to
the part of NATO and European Union I
think it is very important to be focused
on the way to to become member of
European union and that's that
perspective is very clear so I think
that we we have to go in that way and to
discuss to discuss the status of Ukraine
with a with the guarantees uh by a
countries like United States United
Kingdom so I think this is the way how
we can move ahead but you have now
accepted that you will not join NATO
president zielinski has called Ukraine's
failure to gain membership a truth that
must be recognized does the country
accept that now do you accept that
the the the point that Ukraine is going
to become the uh member of NATO was put
into a Ukrainian main law into
Constitution so in case in case that
decision will be on the table and now
it's not on the table we have to change
the Constitution from one side and the
main thing I I strongly believe that
president zielinski in any case will
speak to his people
you're talking about a referendum then
because he's actually spoken about a
referendum
correct absolutely so the statement was
made yesterday and today morning that we
we probably we will use referendums as a
mechanism to establish the the the the
the real situation and to speak to to
ukrainians Mr lemkiski it seems as
though there's a very narrow path to an
agreement and a very high price for
failure the the odds of you finding that
path aren't very encouraging are they
yeah so uh but this is our way this is
our destiny you know uh we we I'm
absolutely confident that we need to win
or to to you know or so this is for for
us something we this is historical
moment for Ukraine uh uh we have a lot
to do in terms of internal life to to
change a lot of things but we want to uh
become the part of Europe I think that
it's it's clear to everybody this that
Ukraine now is defending European values
and this is very important for our
partners to understand and to let
Ukraine join uh European Euro Atlantic
Community well you talk about your
relations with the euro-atlantic
community you didn't get the no-fly zone
that you wanted but you have had
significant amounts of lethal military
aid from the West do you still feel in
any way that the West has let you down
no we are very grateful to all our
partners to all our friends we are we
are grateful to our neighbor Poland our
strategic partner and uh yeah we never
we never get we never got the The
non-fly Zone but uh we are in in very
good cooperation with all our partners
to provide Ukraine with the weapons uh
we need at this stage we need still need
aircrafts and anti-air systems so that
was the the point discussed by my
Minister of Defense Mr Alexi resnicko
yesterday uh with his British colleague
and and polish Minister for of Defense
but more weapons are on their way
Kamikaze drones hundreds of stinger
missiles also different Hardware from
Italy Denmark Germany and other EU
forces
you're happy with the response you got
yes we are your president has seen
particularly annoyed by what he saw as
an inadequate response from Israel is
that true he used some pretty strong
words about them
yeah it was it was a statement to to
knesset and it is in his statement
president zielinski was very clear but
from the other side to make we you know
other relations uh uh with a whether
Israel are very close uh thousands of of
ukrainians live there uh and the the uh
Ukraine is the Homeland for for a lot of
of Israeli people so and that's why his
his statement his address was very
emotional because Ukrainian president is
Jewish so so that's why we really expect
uh from Israel as well as from other
countries like India to to make very
strong and very clear statements related
to Russian aggression but from the other
side we cannot accuse any country you
know that they are providing us with the
weapons over the support or not no we
are grateful for everybody but everybody
should find a way how to help Ukraine
you're surrounded by death destruction
misery in your country
what's been the worst moment for you
personally in the last month
it was a death of a very close friend of
mine
I cannot disclose his his name he's a
real fighter
but that was the the tragedy for first
of all for his family and for for me
personally because I knew that that
person
foreign
how hard is it to to carry on after
something like that
I don't know I don't know it's
impossible you know every death for me
it's like uh it's like shoot into my
into my heart it's not easy to you know
to overcome all these things I'm I'm
quite strong person and I have a lot of
experience based on my book on the
career I mean I I spent in total almost
10 years working in the uh former
Yugoslavia and in in Croatia I used to
be ambassador to that country to Croatia
so it's not easy but uh
something like that happened to me
already it was in 1999 then I spent 78
days in Belgrade during NATO campaign
against the regime of Slobodan milosevic
but that was not my country but I know
what is the war and now walking back to
me again
you talked earlier about the Newfound
unity in Ukraine is it the collective
war effort that motivates people now
yeah you know that you know what was the
idea of putting he he came to Ukraine
with the idea to make free Ukraine from
fascists but he is the real fascist
together with his army and whether his
uh leadership I met a lot of people
coming from hercu from Suma from
chernigue but they were trying to to
leave their places and to move to the
western part of Ukraine and they were
asking me with the only one question we
are half Russians we speak Russian uh we
are fascists a lot of Jews were
approached me with the same question so
Putin accused that people uh that they
are fascists they are not fascists they
ukrainians they love their country and
they will stay stay they they will stay
till the end
so this is this is the make main mistake
I think made by Russian intelligence uh
I think that Putin's dream was to reach
Kiev and to help parade here like in
three four days and that never happened
another mistake may have been to
underestimate the morale of uh the
Ukrainian people
um the polls have been charting the
opinion polls have been charting that
mood have you been surprised at how
upbeat some of them have been the rating
agency did a telephone pole of 1200
people across Ukraine last week 91 said
they felt hope when thinking about the
situation in the country is that really
credible do you think
uh you see the the moral and the spirit
of ukrainians is is very high uh people
are very well motivated uh you know from
one side they're trying to to escape and
they're looking for the safe places but
from the other side I think the support
and the the belief into into our uh
Victory is is very high I I'm very proud
to be Ukrainian I'm very proud to be the
part of this this people
your president has spoken of a strategy
for what he called National resilience
um designed to deal I think with
different scenarios like a full-on
invasion
how detailed is that
strategy and has it helped to give
people confidence do you think
uh I think it's it's too far to speak
English about strategy president is uh
is is is sending to everybody very clear
and very strong messages stay Brave
Ukrainian Army will defend you and I
think that now the main the main
scenario or the main thing is to protect
a Kiev and other cities so as you as you
know Russians did not succeed taking
into surrender Ukrainian cities maybe
the exclusion is is mariopo but the rest
of the cities are are fighting and the
the moral and the spirit of people is an
army is very high your President also
had an unusual phrase he said um we are
on the brink of surviving this War I
think he said that a few hours ago on
the brink of surviving this war
um does that mean that you'll be able to
force a stalemate and is that at the
moment the best you can hope for
I think so I'm absolutely I agree with
her whether my president and the I think
that he was very clear in his words do
you have any confidence that China could
play any mediating role with Russia
because that's something else that
people have suggested or is China only
interested in itself and the chance to
join a new anti-western alliance what do
you think I I think so I I think that
China should not interfere into into
into this war on the Russian side so
it's it's it's the role of of China
should and could be
tremendous you remember that President
Biden sent very strong messages together
with his uh uh the the advisor Sullivan
very strong messages to to China but yes
I think uh so now as as we can see China
is is apart from from from this War I
but I think that the role of China might
be might be significant as this conflict
goes on do you also have your idea your
your thoughts and your concentration on
International Justice is this something
you're thinking of are you documenting
uh the potential war crimes that are
taking place are you working with the
international criminal court the chief
prosecutor who's also expressed interest
in uh putting together evidence and
building
um winnable Grace on war crimes if
that's possible in the future how
important is that idea of international
Justice to you
if we possess we possess a lot of facts
a lot of documents a lot of uh evidences
that can prove that Russia and the
president they are the criminals so we
yes we are going to the international
criminal court we establish already
a good cooperation with them so
investigation is ongoing and we will
provide we already provided and we are
going to provide a lot of evidences to
to that institution
one more interesting thing is that uh
how we can negotiate a hand how we can
make an agreement with the with the
world with international criminal it's
also the question we need to to to find
the answer
do you think you'll ever get your old
life back again Mr lubkiewski or is it
inevitable that you'll have to build a
new kind of Life full of uncertainty and
insecurity
yes
I believe in that you know uh the uh in
2012 I used to be the tournament
director for uh most successful
tournament in the history of UEFA Euro
2012. I was leading the office uh
representing whoever in Ukraine and we
did we did tremendous job that was the
biggest and the most successful project
in my life
I believe I want to to come back to my
usual life
to see my wife my kids
this is normal I think this is the will
of all ukrainians who left their homes
Ki it's been good to have you on
conflict Zone thank you very much for
giving us your time
thank you team thank you so much thank
you for coming with you
[Music]